bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec notion rt france
pourquoi cette volte face du réseau
social qui censurait jusqu'au là on l'a
dit les messages sont les origines
prétendu le colis de 19 octobre face de
la porte de facebook en effet et qobuz
elle revient en réalité à la position
qu'avait et facebook à l'origine
c'est-à-dire à l'origine de la
réglementation juridique de la
responsabilité des et des réseaux
sociaux comme facebook c'est à dire que
ils ne sont qu elle berges du contenu à
partir du moment où les réseaux sociaux
ne sont pas hauteur de toutes les
publications sur le réseau qui sont
faites par l'utilisateur
le droit considère son hébergeur c'est à
dire qu'il n'engage pas leurs
responsabilités et à partir du moment où
ils n'engagent pas leurs responsabilités
non pas bien en place les moyens humains
et techniques pour contrôler tout ce
qu'ils étaient et le contenu illicite ou
provocation à la haine antisémite
raciste et 9 avec cetera aujourd'hui
depuis quelques temps facebook fait des
annonces de manière politique pour dire
qu'il va contrôler les contenus en
réalité je pense que facebook ne
contrôle pas tant de choses que cela est
une nouvelle surprend guère que facebook
décide aujourd'hui de revenir sur sa
position à savoir de ne plus contrôler
les informations qui sont déserts fox
des mauvaises informations ou des
informations de théories du complot sur
locaux vides
en tout cas la décision de facebook
intervient après l annonce de joe biden
on l'a vu sur une enquête ça démontre à
quoi ça démontre que en réalité facebook
finalement en baisse les armes et décide
de manière assez facile de ne rien
contrôler car c'est plus facile pour le
réseau de rien contrôler plutôt que de
mettre en moins au mans en oeuvre les
moyens techniques et humains pour
filtrer les informations qui sont
diffusés chaque jour sur le réseau tout
en sachant qu'il faut faire très
attention car l'on parle de millions
d'informations chaque jour et que donc
même avec des moyens humains il sera
impossible de contrôler toutes les
informations alors est ce que cette
décision elle est conforme à la
politique réglementaire de la plateforme
est-ce que d'une certaine façon cela ne
risque pas de remettre en cause le
respect des normes au sein du réseau
social alors le réseau social facebook
comme twitter ou les autres finalement
modifié au gré du temps leurs conditions
générales et imposent leurs conditions
générales aux utilisateurs le service
est gratuit et en contrepartie les
utilisateurs acceptent ne lis même pas
les conditions générales et cette
volte-face de facebook s'agissant des
infos sur le co vide de l'information
telle théorie du complot du comique sur
le coville finalement démontre démontra
qu'à moi facebook elle finalement refuse
de contrôler et puis aussi surtout est
capable de contrôler les informations
qui sait quelles sont à votre avis quel
message
comment cela est perçu par les
utilisateurs
bon je pense que depuis le début les
utilisateurs ne sont pas dupes
à savoir que facebook ne contrôle pas de
ne contrôle rien et donc en réalité le
fait que facebook aujourd'hui revienne
sur sa position et décide de ne plus
répondre au lait s'agissant des a
fonctionné au vide ne doit pas l'air que
les utilisateurs ne choque je pense
personne ne surprend personne non plus
est ce que ça peut tourner à l'avantagé
de de twitter ou encore de youtube
je ne pense pas que les utilisateurs des
réseaux sociaux recherche de la moralité
dans le réseau ils cherchent chacun
cherche le réseau pour ce qu'il est à
savoir un support de communication un
média et finalement il ne revient pas
forcément médias de d'âge et kt et de la
morale de l'équité et peut-être qu'un
jour ce sera le cas mais aujourd'hui des
lieux facebook et twitter et les autres
bénéficient d'une absence de
réglementation ce qui fait qu'en réalité
ils peuvent varier leur fusil d'épaulé
au gré de leurs envies comme il le
souhaite
et encore cette dernière question
finalement est ce que les états ont leur
mot à dire notamment en europe
lawler en effet en europe depuis
quelques années
l'europe les seuils de se doter d'un
arsenal juridique pour tenter de
responsabiliser les sites et les réseaux
sociaux
le problème c'est que l'europe est
faible voire fragiles face aux sociétés
privées de droits américains tels que
facebook ou twitter ou le droit européen
n'a pas beaucoup d'application on sait
que ce sont des sociétés soumis aux
noirs américains
de sorte que nombreux européens ne
s'applique pas peut-être que demain il y
aura des sanctions qui seront des
sanctions dans financière et qui feront
que les réseaux sociaux aux etats unis
seront obligés de se conformer au droit
européen mais aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
le cas et je crains que dans les années
à venir
les sites internet et aux etats unis
bénéficient d'un paravent d'une
protection grâce aux dons américains au
premier un moment de sorte que le noir
aucun malheureusement ne pouvoir et
merci beaucoup à vous entonnez ben je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat
spécialiste du numérique